compara 98 1989 y 98 1899 queremos
comparar estos dos números y para hacer
eso primero tenemos que pensar en lo que
significan estos dígitos que esto qué
significan estos números observemos
primero nuestro número de la izquierda
tenemos un 9 hasta la derecha o en el
valor posicional de las unidades lo que
significa que son 9 unidades junto a
este número tenemos un 8 en la posición
de las decenas lo que significa 8
decenas y 80 este número que tenemos
aquí 89 es lo mismo que 89 junto al 8
tenemos un 9 en la posición de las
centenas
así que una vez más observamos esto y
tenemos 989 que es lo mismo que 900 más
89 y vamos a continuar y ver los últimos
dos tenemos un 8 en la posición de los
millares
y finalmente tenemos un 9 en la posición
de las decenas de millar lo que
significa nueve decenas de millar o
noventa mil así que 98 mil 989 es lo
mismo que 90.000 más 8000 más 900 más 89
cuál de estas posiciones del valor
posicional parece que es más importante
para decidir qué tan grande es su número
cuál de estos tiene un mayor impacto del
tamaño de nuestro número la respuesta es
el número que tenemos a la izquierda
cualquiera que sea el valor posicional
del número que se encuentra hasta la
izquierda es el mayor valor posicional
así que es el más importante para
decidir qué tan grande o pequeño es un
número así que cuando comparamos estos
dos números vamos a empezar comparando
el mayor valor posicional que tienen
estos números en este caso las decenas
de millar es el mayor valor posicional
que tienen los dos números y en los dos
casos es un 9 así que los dos números
inician con 90.000 por lo que todavía no
podemos decir cuál es mayor así que nos
tenemos que mover a la siguiente
posición del valor posible
la siguiente posición es la de los
millares y nuevamente podemos ver que en
los dos casos tenemos un 8 u 8 mil así
que hasta lo que llevamos en nuestra
comparación estos números son idénticos
ninguno es mayor que otro entonces
debemos continuar y la siguiente
posición del valor posicional son las
centenas y en nuestro primer número
tenemos nueve centenas pero en el número
de la derecha tenemos ocho centenas así
que ha hecho centenas es menor que nueve
centenas entonces este número que
tenemos a la derecha es menor que el que
tenemos a la izquierda o podríamos decir
que 900 es mayor que 800 así que el
número de la izquierda es mayor y este
es nuestro símbolo mayor que porque
queremos que el lado que está abierto
quede de lado del número mayor el lado
abierto debe ir hacia el número mayor y
esto lo leemos como sigue 98 1989 es
mayor que el 98 1899 y probablemente
pienses pero espera no revisamos las
escenas y si observamos las
aquí tenemos 8 decenas pero en la
derecha tenemos 9 decenas y 9 decenas
definitivamente es mayor que 8 decenas
pero eso no hace que el número sea mayor
las antenas son mayores 10 veces mayores
que las decenas así que tienen un mayor
impacto que las decenas para decidir
cuál número es mayor entonces comparamos
hasta encontrar el número que sea
diferente y cualquiera de los dos que
sea mayor en el mismo valor posicional
es el número mayor vamos a intentarlo
con otro aquí estamos comparando 53 mil
y 350 mil y a primera vista podrías
estar pensando ok el primer número es 5
y el primer número es 3 y el 5 es mayor
pero eso no es suficiente tenemos que
estar seguros de que estamos comparando
los mismos valores posicionales
este valor posicional que es el mayor en
este número este 5 está en la posición
de las decenas de millar pero el valor
posicional mayor en este número el 3
está en las centenas de millares así que
en realidad estamos comparando 300000
y 50.000
estos son dos valores posicionales
diferentes queremos comparar centenas de
millar contra centenas de millar y si
observamos de este lado cuántas centenas
de millares tenemos aquí y la respuesta
es cero este número tiene cero centenas
de millar y cuando comparamos eso con
trescientos mil es mucho menor cero
centenas de millar es menor que tres
centenas de millar así que en realidad
este segundo número es mayor entonces
debemos tener cuidado de no solo
comparar el primer número sino que
debemos comparar el valor posicional que
sea mayor y si no hay ningún dígito en
esa posición del valor posicional
podemos ponerle un cero para comparar
así que para leer esto diremos 53.000 es
menor
que 350.000 y este símbolo es menor que
porque el lado más largo está abierto
hacia el número que es mayor y el número
mayor es el segundo así que 53.000 es
menor que 350.000